(upbeat brass band music)
- (indistinct speech)
- Thank you.
- We gotta follow the boss.
(audience chuckles)
- Hello everyone.
And welcome.
So I am thrilled to announce
that the next Dean of Yale
College is Pericles Lewis,
the Douglas Tracy Smith Professor
of Comparative Literature
(audience applauding)
and Professor of English.
Great. Thank you all for joining
us for this announcement.
Thanks to the Yale,
is that the Precision Marching Band,
the concert band random?
Okay, I got it.
Thank you, Tom Duffy, for
assembling a band for us today.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Pericles is joined by his
family, his wife Sheila Hayre,
their daughter, Maya,
and their son, Siddhartha
couldn't join us today
but he is watching on zoom, I understand.
Sheila is a graduate
of the Yale Law School
and currently teaches at
the Quinnipiac Law School.
Siddhartha graduated from
Yale College two days ago
with a BS in Mathematics.
(audience applauding)
We congratulate him.
And Maya is a Yale College sophomore
majoring in English and Biology.
(audience applauding)
So many of you know,
Professor Lewis is an
internationally recognized expert
on the qualities and purposes
of liberal of education.
He's been a talent.
He is a talented faculty member,
been committed teacher
and educator here at Yale
since he joined the faculty in 1998,
and has been deeply involved
in university life ever since.
In addition to teaching
and writing and editing,
Professor Lewis has served now
as the Vice President for Global Strategy
and as a vice provost
for Academic Initiatives.
Among as many contributions
in those roles,
he worked with the Yale
School of Public Health
to launch an online
master's degree program
that we worked with the Jackson Institute
to create a new master's degree
program in Public Policy.
He's worked with the deans of Medicine,
Nursing and Public Health
to establish the Yale
Institute for Global Health,
and his role also included oversight
over the McMillan Center,
the Yale Center Beijing,
the Yale Young Global Scholars Program,
and many other departments and centers.
But his work in the
education of students at Yale
goes back decades.
He was the Director of
Undergraduate Studies
in Comp Lit back in
2000, from 2000 to 2006,
and he helped integrate the two majors
that the department used to sponsor.
He updated the curriculum in 2005.
He worked on the undergraduate
curriculum as a member
and later as Chair of the Yale
College Committee on Majors,
and in his scholarly life, he
works on literary modernism.
He's the author of three books
on the social and intellectual contexts
of modern literature.
And right now he is
working on a manuscript
on the role of liberal education
in developing character,
fostering community, preparing
young people for citizenship,
encouraging the pursuit of knowledge.
Now I think many of you know,
I'm realizing you're
all skewed to one side.
I'm getting you all only in
one hemisphere of my brain
at the moment,
but between 2012 and 2017,
Professor Lewis left Yale
to serve as the Founding
President of Yale-NUS College.
He quickly established himself
as an international authority
on global arts and sciences education.
He oversaw the development
of the Yale-NUS college curriculum,
which was a very innovative curriculum.
He recruited diverse groups of students
and faculty and staff to
work at Yale-NUS College
and as a result of this foundational work,
Yale-NUS College did what
we hoped it would do,
which was inspire innovation
in undergraduate education
first at the National
University of Singapore
then throughout Singapore,
then through other institutions in Asia
and ultimately influence what
we did here domestically,
especially in Yale College.
Now, some of you in this room have worked
with Pericles over the past two years
especially on sustaining Yale's teaching
and research missions during COVID.
That has not been easy
and I wish I could thank individually
so many of you in this room
who played important roles
in getting us through the last two years,
those roles are not over yet,
I wish I could say they were.
But Pericles, as you know
was a very important advisor on COVID 19
because he chaired the
Academic Continuity Committee
which is essentially addressed,
"How do we keep going?
How do we keep pursuing research?
How do we keep pursuing
education and learning
despite the challenges of COVID."
He was also a member of the
Operating Policy Committee
which translated
recommendations we were getting
from Yale's unbelievable
experts in the health sciences,
particularly modeling going on
in the School of Public Health.
How do you translate that
into actions we can take on campus?
So he worked in partnership
with faculty and staff and students,
and figured out how and when
we could welcome students back
to a safe campus environment
and how we could educate them
both remotely and in person.
He oversaw the Poorvu Center
for Teaching and Learning.
As you know, they played a critical role.
Their staff played a critical role
in helping us convert to
online and hybrid education.
During that time he guided
the university planning
for the opening of the Schwarzman Center.
We are now in Commons of
the Schwarzman Center,
this beautiful room that has
been preserved historically
but in ways that are far more functional
than it used to be down below.
I hope virtually everyone
in this room has seen
those beautiful spaces.
And of course, behind that
wall, all kinds of new resources
for students and the
larger Yale community.
He contributed to the planning
of the new Yale Jackson
School for Global Affairs
during this period of time as well.
So on July 1st,
Pericles will step down from
all of those other roles
except for his oversight
of the Schwarzman Center,
and assume the role of
Dean of Yale College.
We will absorb many of
his previous functions
within the Provost's Office
and we're working that out
now and throughout the summer.
There is no doubt, however,
that with his international experience,
we will still turn to Pericles for advice
on all kinds of issues
during these geo politically
complicated times.
He will though focus on his partnerships
with other university leaders,
with the faculty, with the staff,
guiding the curriculum,
the intellectual life
of Yale College, student
affairs in Yale College
and of course with the heads
of the residential colleges
and the deans of residential college,
the experience of life within
the residential communities.
In doing so, he will build
on Dean Marvin Chun's
immense accomplishments
over the last five years
for which we are incredibly grateful,
I've more to say about that in a moment,
ensuring that an undergraduate
education at Yale
is unsurpassed,
unsurpassed by any other
liberal arts college
sitting in the middle of
a research university.
It will be and continue to be
a model for the entire world.
Let me take a moment to thank
the Search Advisory Committee members
chaired by Professor Margaret Clark,
who is also the head of Trumbull College
and Included Professor Aimee Meredith Cox,
Dean Christina Ferando,
Professor Alan Gerber,
former Deputy Dean, Joe Gordon,
Professor Tina Lu, Myan
Chant from the class of 2023,
Professor David Faso,
and my chief of staff, Susan Gibbons
who staffed the committee.
They did enormous amounts of
outreach to the Yale community.
They provided thoughtful recommendations
and a very exciting short
list of potential candidates.
Finally, finally, my heartfelt gratitude
to my partner in crime
here, Dean Marvin Chun.
We are...
(audience applauding)
Dean Chun and I, have been colleagues
in the Psychology department for decades.
I was involved in hiring him
in the Psychology department twice
as well as his wife, Woo-kyoung.
And one couldn't have been
blessed with a better colleague,
a more wonderful friend,
and a Dean more committed
to the life and education
of our undergraduates.
You've been an outstanding leader
for Yale College for the past five years.
I know you share my excitement
about Professor Pericles
Lewis' appointment,
and before turning the podium
over to Professor Lewis,
I want to invite Dean Chun
to say a few words to us.
Once again,
thank you all for being here
and thank you for all
that you do for Yale.
(audience applauding)
Dean Chun.
- Good afternoon.
Please excuse my mask,
I'm following close contact protocols.
I'm wondering where I got exposed.
We just had Commencement
for 20,000 people.
I'm delighted to welcome Professor Lewis
to the best job in academia.
I've long admired his
contributions to Yale
and his achievements as
the Founding President
of Yale-NUS College.
Because I was involved in
the planning of Yale-NUS
and served on their governing board,
I'm in a pretty unique
position to be in awe
of what he had accomplished there.
Professor Lewis had led Yale-NUS College
to become one of the most innovative
liberal arts colleges around the globe
with a curriculum that
is global and inclusive,
a residential life that
successfully incorporated
the best features of
Yale's residential colleges
while adapting to Singapore context.
If you want, you can Google
"Yale-NUS College sky garden."
They have a faculty committed
to collaborative teaching,
a staff dedicated to
both a rigorous education
and student wellness,
and an internationally
diverse student body
that like our students at Yale,
are sought after by top institutions
for their love of learning
and care for others.
I went into detail about
them because I'm excited
for what professor Lewis
will bring to Yale College.
He begins his term as
a Dean of Yale College
with more administrative experience
than I had starting in this role,
and more than I have now
even after completing a five year term.
So frankly, I'm very flattered
to see such an academic
superstar leader as my successor.
In turn, I'm proud and happy
to be passing on a college
that is flourishing as best as one can
after a challenging
two years for everyone.
The Yale College Dean's
Office is more collaborative,
proactive and resilient than before
because that is how the
faculty staff and students
have all been.
I'm grateful to President Salovey
for entrusting me with this role.
And I thank him for
supporting Yale College and me
so strongly throughout my entire term.
Every significant request I made
such as the elimination
of billed student effort
and financial aid and the
Camp Yale orientation flip,
he has granted with enthusiasm.
I also thank Provost Scott Strobel.
He has provided all the
guidance and resources needed
to manage through the pandemic,
culminating in the renaissance
of in-person campus life
and two glorious commencement weekends.
Provost Strobel has
positioned Yale College
for greater success in the years ahead,
building on former
Provost Ben Polak's legacy
by approving significant
enhancements to financial aid,
residential life, student life,
and of course, academic
programs and facilities.
It's kinda like starting
with a blank check.
(Professor Pericles chuckles)
Much of the college's work
is powered by our distinguished
faculty colleagues
led by Faculty of Arts and
Sciences, Dean Tamar Gendler,
School of Engineering
and Applied Science Dean,
Jeff Brock and FAS Steering Group.
Yale College also works closely
with the Graduate School
led by Lynn Cooley,
and we are grateful for
our academic partnerships
with the professional schools
where our undergraduate
students are fortunate
to take classes and pursue majors.
I'd like to remind everyone here
that Yale College depends
on the entire university
and so I am grateful for
having worked regularly
with the Yale Alumni
Association, Yale Athletics,
Chaplain's office, Facilities
and Grounds, General Counsel,
Yale Health, Yale Hospitality,
Information Technology Services,
Human Resources Operations,
Police and Public Security,
Office of Public Affairs,
Secretary's office,
and also other key offices
that Professor Lewis
has supervised already,
the Registrar's Office, the Poorvu Center,
Conferences and Events, Global Strategy,
and the Schwarzman Center.
We have incredibly caring
alumni parents and friends
who support our mission
with inspiring generosity,
and their gifts are managed wisely
by the three offices
of Development, Investments, and Finance.
I believe that Yale has the most vibrant
residential college
communities in the world
led by prominent heads,
deans, and staff members
devoted to our students.
I will always be proud and grateful
to have served as head of Berkeley college
as much as I am to have served
as Dean of Yale College.
Each year, the Yale College Dean's office
trains over 200 student leaders.
First year counselors, peer
liaisons, peer mentors,
communication and consent
educators, committee members,
and student staff members
in our offices and cultural centers.
And working independently
but in close collaboration,
Yale College Council
is an essential partner
to help the Dean understand
and support student needs.
The Yale College Dean's office itself
has over 230 outstanding staff members
across the offices of Academic Affairs,
Admissions and Financial
Aid, Administrative Affairs,
Center for International
and Professional Experience,
Strategic Initiatives and Communication,
the Council of Heads of College,
the Residential College Dean's Offices,
Development, External
Affairs and Special Projects,
Finance, Student Affairs,
Student Engagement and
the Cultural Centers,
and Undergraduate Education.
Led by fantastic senior
associate deans and directors,
I view each office to be the best
across all of higher education.
My biggest joy in the deanship
was working with such brilliant
and dedicated colleagues
who are now like a second family to me.
We've been through a lot,
and my colleagues gave everything
they have, day and night,
without weekends or
recess, to the students,
to each other and me, and to Yale.
Friends, I really appreciate
you and I love you.
Dean Lewis, you will love them too.
The entire Yale College
Dean's office and I
are thrilled to support your deanship.
Thank you for accepting the
role and congratulations.
(audience applauding)
(indistinct speech)
- Thank you, Dean Chun.
We so appreciate your leadership.
And now I'd like to introduce
the next Dean of Yale College,
Pericles Lewis.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much, president Salovey.
Could I invite those who
are at that end of the room
to come over into the middle
of the room if you're willing?
It's good to get a little circulation.
Thank you.
Don't worry, I won't
keep you for too long.
Thank you so much President
Salovey and Dean Chun.
President Salovey, thank
you for your leadership
and for entrusting this
important role to me.
Thanks also to the members of
the Search Advisory Committee.
I really appreciate your confidence.
And Dean Chun,
thank you for the inspiring
work that you have done
in the past five years
under some of the difficult circumstances
that you mentioned to lead this community.
It's really a true honor
to be named your successor
and I appreciate your very kind words.
Next year will be the 25th
since I joined Yale College
as a faculty member and started teaching.
The college is a remarkable institution
dedicated to light and truth.
And even though we may all
pursue truth by our own lights,
one of the great things about the college
is the way that we work together,
we try and help light each other's way.
The fact that we are all
pursuing truth together
is part of what makes this a place
of great learning and communal joy
and what makes the four years
that our undergraduates spend with us
so transformative for them
and also truthfully transformative for us,
the faculty and the staff.
Next academic year will be the fourth year
since the beginning of the pandemic.
The class of 2023
has never known a totally
COVID-free year at Yale.
And these last few years
have made the central act of Yale College,
which is learning together,
somewhat more challenging,
considerably, more challenging.
I'd like to salute the
students and the faculty
and especially the staff
who have persevered
during challenging times
and who've made it possible for us
to continue our educational mission
and also our great research
during this challenging period.
In particular, I'm very
grateful to the heads
and the deans of the residential colleges,
to the Yale College Dean's Office staff,
to the staff of the residential colleges,
and also of course, to our colleagues
in hospitality and
facilities, because they've,
all of you together have
kept this place open
and made it possible for students to learn
even at a time when, at
times it has been challenging
and when guidelines on public
health have been changing
and sometimes it has been stressful.
I thank you for that,
and I hope that this is a an opportunity
for some well deserved rest
for people who have been working
so hard the last few years.
I also know that many of you
have been through a difficult period
and I look forward to supporting the staff
in their essential roles as we go forward.
I believe that next year
we'll have the opportunity
to recover from the worst of COVID
and to experience the
transformative communal life
of college together more intensely
in the arts and in athletics,
in the residential colleges
and the cultural houses,
in study abroad and volunteer work,
in the library and in the laboratory,
in the classroom, and in
extracurricular activities.
And I look forward to
participating in that.
Next yea will be the 323rd
year of Yale College.
The college began by educating
young men from Connecticut
and Western Massachusetts in
the liberal arts and sciences
in the words of the Charter,
to prepare them for public
employment both in church
and civil state,
and only eight students graduated
at the first commencement
in New Haven, more than 300 years ago.
Since then, while the college's goal
of educating talented young people
for future leadership has not changed,
Yale has continually expanded,
not only in terms of pedagogy,
not only in terms of numbers,
but also in the range
of subjects we teach,
the excellence of our curriculum
and pedagogy and research,
and the diversity of our student body.
For almost a century,
the residential colleges
have created enduring communities
that are an essential part of
the broader Yale ecosystem.
I could not be prouder of the
progress that Yale has made
in the past 60 years to become a college
that better reflects the great diversity
of the United States
and that welcomes students
regardless of ability to pay
from around the world.
(audience applauding)
There's of course, much more work to do
and like our sister
schools here and abroad,
we've faced some tumultuous
times over the last few years
but I believe in a Yale where everyone,
regardless of race or
socioeconomic status,
gender, sexuality or gender
identity or expression,
disability or veteran status,
religious or political perspective
or national or ethnic
origin, can learn together.
And such an environment for
learning requires respect
and tolerance and a willingness
to listen to one another.
Most of all, it requires an openness
on the part of each of us.
An openness to learn and a
humility, (sobs) excuse me.
A humility about how
little we actually know.
I promise I won't do this
every time I make a speech.
(audience laughs)
Yale's world leading research,
our dedicated teachers
our distinctive residential system,
and what I think of as
the civil society of Yale,
the web of groups and
traditions and activities
that make up its unique culture,
these are worth cherishing and preserving.
They've been underpinned over the years
by an ethos of service.
While we of course want our students
to develop their talents fully
and their characters as individuals,
we also expect that the Yale Alumni
will make broader contributions
to the communities that
they choose to live in
and will use their capacities
to the highest possible ends.
So we hope that our students carry
the dedication to light and truth
with them beyond their
four years in the college.
Thank you again for this honor.
I take it on in a spirit
of openness and humility.
In closing, I'd like to thank my family,
some of whom are with me
and some of whom are Yale graduates,
and as was mentioned,
one of whom is a very
recent Yale graduate indeed.
I'm grateful to the teams
in global strategy and
academic initiatives.
I'm happy to see so many of you here.
You've worked tirelessly
over the last five years
to ensure that the mission
of this great university,
a research university that
as President Salovey has said
puts teaching at its
core, remains central.
To the team I'm joining in Yale College,
I look forward to getting
to know you better,
to continuing to provide
the world's greatest
undergraduate education.
To the faculty,
thank you for your
continued collegial support
and dedication to our mission.
To the students, have a wonderful,
exciting restful summer.
I can't wait to see you all
in the new academic year
and in the words of the old
Yale football song, Boola Boola.
I probably should have
warned the band about that
so they could start playing
it, but anyway, boola boola.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Let me just thank Maya and
Sheila for joining us today.
Once again, Dean Chun, for
your incredible stewardship
of Yale College,
and professor Lewis, Pericles Lewis,
thank you for saying
yes when I called you.
I think you can all
see, this is a man who,
whose emotional commitment
to this position is obvious
and whose passion for the
position is so readily on display.
We're going to make him wear a mask
for all future speeches, however.
(Professor Pericles laughs)
Thank you all for joining us
today for this announcement.
We have refreshments,
courtesy of Yale Hospitality.
We ask you to join us in
celebrating this moment
by partaking.
Thank you all for being here
and thank you all for what
you do for Yale College.
(audience applauding)